listen to me something is wrong
something is wrong with me this movie
you guys had me in such a rollercoaster
of emotions the entire time it's not
like your typical horror flick though so
from your perspective how would you
describe this been so difficult
challenging to describe because first
and foremost there are a lot of things
that are spoilers about it because the
movie pretty quickly starts makes sure
that you're aware that what you're
seeing is probably not the objective
reality of the situation and so it's
really hard to describe beyond to tell
us who came out of the same Academy end
up judging a competition together in
Shanghai and there's a lot between them
yeah you know they have never met and
well there you go
have they never met did you guys learn
to play the cello for this yeah yeah you
guys can actually play can isn't
interesting at the present tense that
you use there is sadly not the case
there's not an instrument coming out for
you for us to perform right now no it is
too challenging and we had ambitions to
be jealous for the rest of our life and
I thought it was just gonna become part
of my life I'd you know I'd have a check
my cello when I went to the airport and
I'd bring it everywhere with me and
sadly that just did not happen yeah and
if anyone could do it would have been us
and we did not so I guess I wasn't
possibly yeah you know what you have to
do I feel like you're becoming this
ultimate scream queen you think about
that going into this following this
success of get out I think I'm the
opposite of a scream queen and that I'm
not doing much of I'm making other
people yeah what I thought about going
into it from get out was just that it's
Charlotte my character no perfection is
so nicely a sort of picks up on and uses
the associations people might have with
me from get out and in a way that I
think works for the movie and is helpful
to the movie I knew that in some kind of
meta way if people are fans of the genre
they might have seen get out going into
this it would be helpful it's not like I
was just I said I only send me scripts
that are psychological it just happens
to be because I think like we both feel
that you can get into more intense
subject matter in a different way in
this genre
that was attracted to both of us when I
read the script absolutely something is
wrong with me Lizzie I know that's why
we need to get you help very steamy
scenes in this movie yes and I always
hear that sex scenes are the worst to
film does that ring true here what if we
were both like yeah it was terrible no
yes it is like I have made um quite a
few of them it was great it was a delay
honestly it was the best one of the best
experiences I've ever had especially
when you want to talk about the
technicalities of filming yeah it seemed
like that there was literally no one in
that room who didn't need to be in there
and I think as actors it at least for me
personally it really allowed me to feel
completely comfortable knowing no one's
standing at a monitor and and we could
just be in that moment oh my god
obviously there's themes of competition
and jealousy and I feel like we very
much live in a world and even this
industry where women are constantly
pitted against other women what's the
solution to that and have you guys
experienced that in Hollywood do us
that's what I would say I do what is the
solution that's cool
there's not one solution to any problem
I think that that's the way things are
resolved is coming at them from
different angles and everyone having
great ideas because when everyone gets
an opportunity to try to resolve
something you like think about the civil
rights movement you needed people who
were protesting you needed people who
were you know lobbying you needed people
you need lawyers you need everyone from
different angles so when it comes to
solving the this one issue I think it's
it's a matter of the duets and it's a
matter of the choir it's a matter of
everyone being a part of the solution
and not just women you know it's a
matter of the men being in the room - I
love that well on the flip side there's
also you know women
just kind of a message in this movie in
a sense can you guys speak to that and
what you hope people will take away
after they finish watching this I think
what you're seeing is just to hopefully
um reel in all of the strangest weirdest
most imperfect ways ironically given the
title of the movie people and I think
that the two our characters are people
who are on their journey to figuring out
who they are what they want who they are
when no one's looking and how to be that
person when people are looking and I
think for anyone that ends up being when
you feel most empowered and most sort of
I don't know a self actualized I think
it's it's a really hard place to get to
and it's a it's a lifelong pursuit but I
think we get to see the two of them on
their way there if not in some ways
already arrived at various points in the
movie I hope people feel really
nauseated when they leave and I hope you
second-guess your friends I hope you
wonder you know if your parents should
have forced you to play that instrument
growing up very different answers I feel
like this movie is gonna take off in the
way that bird box did like it's gonna
that would be very active but are you
guys ready for that yeah yeah we'll be
here yeah we'll be in this exact hotel
come find us the lights will go out I'm
sure and we will just be sitting here
with that behind us I just we're ready
we're just ready I will probably change
maybe shower couple times look before
maids back or at least we could do
yeah that's a wolf we're ready we'll be
there what is it I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]